hey what's going on it's bill burr and
it's time for the thursday afternoon
just before friday monday morning
podcast and
i'm just checking it on you i'm just
checking to see
if you can still pee if you're old like
me you can't
i'm kidding anyway um what's going on
nice to be here nice to be here
um i i saw i saw oh i saw something on
the internet i cannot get to a [ __ ]
stand-up stage fast enough
it was just such a gift from the comedy
gods
i don't even know what angle to drop
there's just every [ __ ] angle
is funny
when i gonna tell you the topic some
[ __ ] idiot guy
hooked himself up to a car battery so he
could see what it felt like to deliver a
baby
i mean just i mean sometimes you gotta
dig for the comedy
and other times it's just presented on a
pillow
one of them royal pillows right somebody
comes in
dressed with his [ __ ] socks yanked up
to his knees you know the little puffy
pants
yeah you are sir ten minutes of [ __ ]
material unbelievable
unfucking believable jesus christ
it's just i i can't you know but i'm
actually uh
i'm going to a wedding this weekend um
oh billy twinkle toes is going to be on
the dance floor oh my god a white man
sober at a [ __ ] wedding
oh being dragged out on the dance floor
jesus christ
oh my god if i could just get through
that
i think i'll be all right
[Music]
casual question why isn't it okay with
people that dance that other people
don't dance why can't they just leave us
alone
why can't you just leave i'm having a
good time
i don't need to be twirling around
[ __ ] ripping my suit or whatever the
[ __ ] it is you're doing
you're good at it that's just that's
what you should be doing fantastic
why do i have to [ __ ] go out there i
don't want to go out there
can't i just sit over here and just
[ __ ] you know
have something to eat talk to somebody
got to go out there like [ __ ] fred
astaire [ __ ] jumping around poles and
[ __ ] i mean i i just don't understand i
just
do not understand why that is a part of
a wedding
like a required part of it like if i
showed up
you know i i wore the suit i i applaud
it i brought a gift
nope you don't get credit unless you get
out take those old records off the shelf
why
christ
and then your [ __ ] chick gets mad if
you don't [ __ ] go out there
come on out here i don't
wh do i do i get mad at you when you
don't want to go to a football game you
say it's boring i like the grass the
grass is pretty
do i go like oh i'm like so [ __ ] mad
at you right it's like i get it you
don't want to do this [ __ ] i will never
do this to you again nope
i've been joking with my wife all week
i'm like i'm not doing it
okay i'm in therapy right now and
my i'm gonna make my for the first time
in my life my nose are gonna mean no
i i am not i am not drinking merlot
no it was kidding i'm gonna get out
there i'll have a good time
but i'm just [ __ ] i refuse to try
you know you want me to go out there
i'll go out there okay
it's i just i don't understand it i just
don't i've never
understood it it's it's like you go to a
bar there's drinking there's darts
you know you if you're going and you get
shit-faced you're fine you know if you
didn't play darts
you know you still get credit for
drinking
you can still get pulled over for
drinking and driving people at the bar
are like hey hey come on get out here
get out of here brother
draw the [ __ ] dots
come on it's fun right it's just like
why can't i just [ __ ] why
can't you just let me be the socially
introverted mess that i am can't you
just let me be that
oh christ
it's unbelievable um
but you know what it's the balance of
life because the comedy gods gave me
that [ __ ] [ __ ]
oh my god oh i cannot i can't i can't
[ __ ] wait i mean like
there's like jokes in my act that are
gonna have to be removed they're gonna
lose a spot in the lineup
i can't wait with the thoughts that i
have about that i just cannot wait
to get all of that out of me and uh the
next couple of nights
you know is the whole the whole wedding
you know i just found out too that
you know my wife is like okay this i'm
wearing this for the for the
rehearsal dinner and i'm wearing this
for the wedding what do you think i'm
like it's great i need two outfits
she's like yeah it's
it's the night all right okay i can fix
that
i'm gonna do the old uh one suit two
shirt [ __ ] move oh you like that
white shirt black shirt
white shirt black shirt red fish blue
fish that's one of those dr seuss books
that's what i'm doing
that's what the [ __ ] i'm doing
yeah i just want to go there and have a
good time the way i have a good time
okay the way i do it
okay but for some reason these these
happy people that had
pleasant childhoods want to drag you
into the fairy tale of their life and
you just like
just can you just respect what i came up
with
all right
i'm just [ __ ] around but i would be
lying to you if if i didn't say i
i i don't have a little anxiety
um it's
you know but not as much anxiety i'm
sitting there [ __ ] you know watching
the goddamn olympics and all these uh
you know all of these people what's
going on though they say the russians
are banned but they're still there
it's just like has the world just gone
[ __ ] crazy it's like they're banned
they're not there look at this guy he
looks like he's russian
could he be russian so who gives a [ __ ]
who gives a [ __ ] if they go there and
win and they're playing for another
country who cares
who gives a [ __ ] like who gives a [ __ ]
if russia won
all the medals
aren't we past who gives a [ __ ] oh
are you better at badminton than we are
i don't give a [ __ ] if the russians are
better ass than badminton
i give a [ __ ] if they're coming over the
wall and they're pissed those guys are
[ __ ] crazy
you know you want to go [ __ ] you know
beat somebody at ping pong
oh can you do the backstroke better than
some guy from [ __ ] uh
czechoslovakia i don't give a [ __ ]
i don't give a [ __ ] i'll watch it i'll
enjoy it
i don't understand why are they bad
that's stupid that's like taking darth
vader out of a [ __ ] star wars movie
now what do you got
why are the russians banned are the
russians
band how do you spell band i'm spelling
band like you want to start a band man
okay i don't know what happened it just
like crossed out half the [ __ ] i wrote
2019 the world anti-doping agency
banned russians from all international
sporting competitions
uh they just can't get sober over there
can they
including the olympics for four years
over a doping scandal what is this their
900th they're like the [ __ ] usc of
countries
uh the punishment was cut in half two
years ago
pale whoa
by the court of arbitration for sport
following a 2020 what they give you some
plutonium
hey can you make this go away uh italian
accent for [ __ ] russians i don't know
why bill
all right a 2020 appeal and now ends in
december
2022.
all right what was the dope why are the
russian athletes competing at the tokyo
olympics despite
wait they're there wearing russian dude
that's hilarious they just crashed it
all right wait a second why are the
russian athletes competing at tokyo
olympics despite the country's ban
sporting authorities do not want to
punish clean athletes or cut off the
money
well yeah if they're clean that's fine
you know somebody next to me in class
flunks
but i pass why should i have to go to
summer school too
you like how i passed the class in that
scenario the reality was i was the guy
going to summer school
when is an international olympic team
not an international olympic team
when it's the russian olympic committee
officially russia is banned
oh b-a-n-n-e-d not b-a-n-d-e-d
banded such a dope from competing in
tokyo
for previous doping offenses give me
drugs give me drugs
but viewers would be forgiven for
thinking otherwise a team of 335
athletes from russia is competing under
the name of the roc
what does that stand
russian oxy cocaine heads russian oxy
cokeheads i'm sorry
wearing white blue and red uniforms and
winning plenty of medals
russia i mean you got to love that i
mean you got to love you know
some punk rock about that something
rebellious i like it russia has
repeatedly violated anti-doping laws
have the rules been tough enough
at the winter olympics in vancouver in
2010 russia won 15 medals putting its
11th in the table
the [ __ ] does that mean four years later
in the russian resort
of sochi it came first with third it
came in first with 30 medals
they were working out day and night
those guys some of this improvement
could be down to home advantage
australia china and britain each
improved their metal halls when they
hosted the summer games in recent years
but as
but russian athletes received a more
subtle leg up in the form
of an extensive state-sponsored doping
program
yeah yeah what a [ __ ] thing to waste
drugs on
let's see who can [ __ ] ski faster
down a [ __ ] hill it's so
dumb why don't they cure paralysis
you know what what are we doing it's so
[ __ ] dumb i don't i don't [ __ ] i
like the olympics i like
watching it and i i like seeing somebody
win
and be happy and i feel sad when
somebody blows it
regardless of what country they're from
you know what i mean
unless they're playing like a real sport
like hockey basketball
you know i used to like us basketball
until they let the nba guys play that i
i can't get into it
although the the european teams are good
now so maybe it's good maybe we up the
the
the level i guess i don't [ __ ] know i
don't know a lot of things
all right i don't know much but i don't
give a [ __ ] if you win a medal
um all right more sad news more sad news
rest in peace
uh joey jordanson the incredible drummer
from slipknot
um just gone way
way way too soon i was like 45 46 years
old
um i mean talk about a guy that just
influenced i don't know how many like
probably two full generations of kids to
play double bass all these
kids you see playing blindingly fast
you know he's part of that whole you
know lars dave lombardo
all of those guys that whole legacy
those speed metal drummers which you
know
i was more of a hair metal guy i got
into this [ __ ] a little bit later but
jesus christ
um such sad sad news
uh and dusty hill from zz top
who i couldn't believe was 71 72 years
old
sent me down this friggin i don't know
what do they call it rabbit hole i'm
just seeing how many musicians are dead
from the 80s don't ever do that to
yourself if you're my age my god
there were so many people i didn't know
the guy who's saying i [ __ ] stopped
it out of
africa i didn't know he was dead
a lot of [ __ ] dead people man 30
years goes by a lot of people die
there you go bill that was brilliant
thank you that's why we listened to the
podcast that was such a stupid statement
um lot of musicians
thirty years is musicians seem to age in
dog years man this is just being on the
[ __ ] road
especially those older guys man because
they were sort of the uh the lab rats
are doing the road like nobody knew
you know nobody knew like i think he
like i don't even think like uh the
betty ford clinic came out until like
betty ford right
i mean how many times did betty ford
have to make an ass of herself before
like
that's when you know you're [ __ ] up
when they like name the clinic after you
i mean that is a first ballot hall of
fame drunk you know what
give it up for betty ford i bet she was
fun to drink with um
yeah dusty hill great unbelievable band
zz top and one of the tightest bands
you'd ever see
and i was actually listening to them
today and there was a song that they
were playing and it literally
sounded like slowed down pantera
because those are two of the tightest
bands ever
and they were both in a way a power trio
except uh
pantera had the extras they didn't have
a you know
the guitar player didn't sing lead so
all right i think i've made enough of an
ass of myself uh so rest in peace
joey jordanson and uh dusty hill
um yeah man just with all these people
jeff lebar all these people dying it's
just taking me back i actually you know
been watching these old concerts and
then i'm just
looking and all of this [ __ ] and it's
like bill you have to [ __ ] understand
that when you were in the 1980s and you
look back at the 1950s
how long ago that seemed that's what
kids today
are kind of looking at the 80s as that's
how long ago that was it's actually
now we were basically what would have
been in my life like 1991 for these kids
is 2021.
if that made any [ __ ] sense the math
made sense in my head that's how that's
what i do
i always take it back to the 80s or the
90s right
if i think about the 70s like what does
that feel like to a kid today that's 20
i just go back to when i was 20 1988
right if you went back you know
40 years that'd be 1948.
it's a [ __ ] centuries ago to a young
kid
you just don't realize it because if
you're like me
you know somewhere around like i don't
know 19 you stop learning
so you just feel like you're in the same
grade and all of a sudden like four
[ __ ] decades goes by
um anyway i went to the gym
still crushing it i haven't been doing
so good with the diet i got off the diet
a little bit but i've still been
crushing it
um at least going to the gym and i've
been eating
like i'd say but instead of eating
perfectly i've been eating like you know
eighty percent well but it's hard you
know my daughter wakes up dad can you
make me some pancakes
i'm like yeah how do you make pancakes
for one [ __ ] person you can't do it
right then my wife's like i'm not eating
those
i can't i'm doing my diet she's crushing
it on her diet
so i'm like well we're going away for
the weekend you know i always say you
know i hear on the rogan podcast he puts
butter in his
coffee before he works out is that what
he does i'll put butter on my pancakes
you know i'll put a little syrup on it
so i kind of skip into the gym today
so i went in there today i did legs
legs and eggs hey guys come on down to
foxy lady for legs and eggs
i'll never forget that being in a dental
office and we had easy lists i don't
know what [ __ ] station could have
been easy listening
they're advertising a [ __ ] titty bar
as we're filling somebody's tooth and
the guy's whispering on the radio like
like you your wife couldn't hear in the
car hey guys
come on down this thursday to the foxy
lady for legs and eggs
like sneak down for breakfast and stare
at another woman's snatch
why you have a bacon egg and cheese
biscuit
and then you can go to work hating
yourself
carl is everything all right with you oh
yeah i just didn't sleep well last night
you sure you didn't go to a titty bar
and look at other vaginas
while having a breakfast bisque biscuit
um made a black bean burger whole batch
of those things
um got a really good recipe for it but i
think uh
you know they hate when they go cook it
10 to 15 minutes they said bake the
beans for like [ __ ] 10 to 15 minutes
so it's not all watery and soggy
but 10 to 15 minutes is literally like
an extra third and i just think i cooked
it too [ __ ] long
just sort of dried the [ __ ] out a little
bit so uh
next time i'll do it like eight to ten
minutes
and i'll add a couple more things i
needed a little citrus in there though i
can tell you that
but uh won't [ __ ] cook them as long
either in the pan but uh
whatever they're healthy but doing that
you know went out with my wife the other
night to some little social event we
played bingo
oh god what happened my life actually
had a great time doing that
ordered something healthy and uh
got the [ __ ] out of there when they
brought the chocolate chip cookies and
[ __ ] around in the end i i you know i
didn't
i didn't partake so i go to the gym
today i do
i do the legs right i start with the
calves i work my way up a lot of people
work their way down
you know they start with glutes then
they go to the thighs then they go to
the calves
then they do the little twinkle toes
right that's not how i do it i start
with the toes
right up down up down up down then i go
to the calf seated calf
machine alley-oop thing off to the side
bank does bank does bank does right do
three [ __ ] sets of those
all right i wipe it off covid you know
as i stare down someone else at the gym
like did you catch that action over here
sweetheart
all right then i end up with the the
[ __ ] nasa squat machine
you know i'm not doing that [ __ ]
standing up where i got to have the bar
on my shoulder
i'm not doing the one where i'm laying
down i like the one where it's like
you're in
one of the first [ __ ] uh the hat's
just blue
like the [ __ ] the original we're
going to the moon
right or a sound stage in houston
depending on what [ __ ] part of the
internet you're on
that one the hack squat i do that i do
not lock my legs out
you do not lock your legs you lock your
legs that tendon on the back of your
[ __ ] knees gonna wreak havoc on you
dodge bang dash bang bang bang [ __ ]
three sets of those
wipe it down and then i sit down and
then i do the [ __ ]
it's basically the triceps of your legs
the front part your lap
i get on the lap machine you know
i'm playing santa at the mall this year
i got to make sure i can handle these
fat kids sitting on my [ __ ] thighs
do all my sciatic nerve to [ __ ] act
up again
so i bang those out and then i get on
the [ __ ] elliptical
and i try to do seven thousand whatever
steps
in 45 minutes and i try to get north of
600 calories
that's what i do and but what old
freckles did was i forgot
to bring up the backup t-shirt for the
car
ride home so you know i'm [ __ ] you
know i look like somebody
took a garden hose to me so fortunately
you know the gym sells
stuff and i bought all of their t-shirts
because i keep forgetting so anything
left that i didn't have was the tank top
now i have not worn a tank top
since the [ __ ] 80s all right
hey now hey now um
so i put the tank top on it oh my god i
look like i could i had like grandmother
arms
there was nothing cut nothing defined
freckles as far as the eye could see
you know and it was a large too it was
still tight around my [ __ ] belly
i just [ __ ]
you know what i look like i look like
the guy you know when the cops come to
the door i look like the guy who
answered the door
[Laughter]
ah jesus christ i [ __ ] hate myself
i gotta lose this [ __ ] weight then
tonight was like movie night and i watch
wall-e with my daughter
and she wants to learn how to make
popcorn i made the popcorn then i had a
root beer stupid i got to get back on it
man but you know
i am at least going to the gym i was
eating like that not even going to the
gym and i became old [ __ ]
michelin man bill you know you would
think i would have got a call from them
you know and maybe
advertise on the podcast
used to be mr clean you know that guy
was [ __ ] shredded
his bald [ __ ] head but you know the
guy filled out a t-shirt you wouldn't
call that guy baldy would you there was
something really [ __ ]
like you know
don't [ __ ] with me about mr clean
you know what i mean he he the guy had a
vibe
it's like yule brenner you know in uh
westworld the original
all right this is what i should have
done this is what i should have done had
i known i needed another suit i would
have gone to indochino
the right outcome share a story of the
time you felt confident with the look
you put together
oh when i did the uh when i was
presenting on the grammys and i thought
it was going to be on tv
i felt so confident until i walked into
a sound stage in burbank and i realized
oh wait a minute i'm on the internet
portion of it
but i felt good and i look good and i
look good
you know uh the right outfit can bring
something special in us
to bring out something specialist and
within cheeto
creating your best look yet could be
more affordable than you think
it may have been a while since the last
time you had an excuse to dress up
but whenever that next chance is make
the absolute most of it with indochito
indochino indochino offers completely
custom fitted suits shirts casual wear
and more at surprisingly
affordable prices every piece is made to
your exact measurement
and you can customize every detail you
know whichever way it hangs they'll cut
the slack to make it [ __ ] you know
choose everything about your suit from
the fabric lapel monogram and
statement linings
statement linings what do you have on
this [ __ ] written on the inside of your
suit
you can create a suit that fits you and
your style perfectly the best part
indochino suit started just at 3.99
with all customizations included
indochino is now open at select
nordstrom stores giving you even more
ways to get
great fitting personalized clothing find
your nearest location
at indochino.com right now you can get
off any purchase of 3.99 or more by
using the code bur at checkout that's 50
off a purchase at 399. or more at
n d o c h i n o indo
chino i n d o
c h i n o dot com promo code burr
the candid company everybody candid co
ceo
candid co uh there's a specialist for
just about everything right
when your car breaks down you go to a
mechanic when there's a problem with the
shower
i call a plumber if there's a virus i
listen to doctors
um so so when you want to get your
uneven crooked teeth fixed
you see an orthodontist they're the
specialist
and that's what sets candid the
invisible
comfortable and removable aligners above
the rest
while poorly reviewed or insanely priced
clear
aligner companies use general dentists
candid only works with the masters
the specialist the orthodontist with
candid the same orthodontist who created
your plan
is with you from start to finish so you
never have to wonder how you're doing
your treatment is prescribed and closely
monitored remotely
by a licensed orthodontist who's an
expert in tooth movement
you can book an appointment at a can
candid studio near you
or do everything from the comfort and
convenience of your own home
the average candid candid treatment is
just six months
you'll start seeing results way before
then and it costs thousands less than
traditional braces
it's amazing and with your free with
your liner treatment you'll get cannon's
teeth whitening for free
candy can help you get the straighter
brighter smile you've always wanted
right now
you can save 75 on your candid starter
kit
when you get started from home or you
can book an appointment at a candid
studio near you today
go to candidco.com
and use the code bird b-u-r-r that's
candidco.com
codebird take advantage of this limited
time offer to save 75
dollars on your starter kit candidco.com
code burr
all right jesus christ what have i got
here a couple more oh look who it is
everybody ultimate ears
ultimate ears talk about the essential
technology you use daily whether you use
one device
all day or switch between several
oh these are these inner ear things that
they got me yeah these things these
things are slick i like them better than
those
those other guys there the guy with the
turtleneck uh
with how much we rely on devices it's
easy to forget about the hardware we're
born with
like the ear same as fingerprints no two
are exactly alike that's why
your earbuds probably cause you some
discomfort or even physical pain after a
while i've been there
the ultimate the ultimate ear fits true
wireless custom fit
earbuds from the ultimate ears are here
to change that
oh the ultimate ear fits true wireless
custom fit earbuds from the ultimate
ears are here to change that
ultimate ear fits fits
um are the world's most comfortable
earbuds premium sound all day
comfortable
all-day comfort they are comfortable as
hell i'll tell you that much better than
those straws that other country company
gives you
uh you get a guaranteed perfect fit in
60 seconds
ultimate ears fit will stay put when you
uh when you're on the go
but feel ultra comfortable so you can
wear them all day long without pain or
discomfort
using groundbreaking light form
technology ultimate ears fit
mold to your the unique contours of your
ear i got to tell you something i've
been using these on the elliptical 45
minutes
uh i have not had any i used to get like
irritation from the other ones
um these ones i do not with eight hours
of continuous playback
on a single charge in up to 20 hours
with the charging case ultimate ears fit
uh
fits are perfect for listening to your
favorite shows like this one all day
long you could also go on a flight all
the way to hong kong
and not have to recharge them um
built on industry leading expertise
trusted by pro musicians and hi-fi
enthusiasts for over 25 years engineers
to provide a full warm sound with a
tight punchy low end
and you can cuss and you can and you can
set
custom eq
presence presets oh sorry through the
app too
jesus christ that's one of the hardest
sentences i ever read and you can set
custom eq presets through the app too
jesus playing pause music and answer
calls with built-in controls
i mean they got everything if you try
fits and you don't love them as much as
i do no worries
ultimate ears offers a 30-day money-back
guarantee but you're gonna love these
things
plus you get free shipping free returns
and a one year warranty for a limited
time
you get 15 off your first pair of
ultimate ear fits
true wireless earbuds at ue dot com
slash fits just use the promo code bur
burr
at checkout that's 15 off with the promo
code bur
at ue.com fitz
all right lastly
but not leastly
uh oh wait no that that was the last
this is a dynamic read
this is for something else so i know i
got to read that all right well look at
that it's
30 minutes just like that now i can pack
for the wedding
right get down get ready
i'm gonna have a good time um
i'll tell you when i go to weddings
that's when i really wish i was still
drinking
you know what i mean just getting up
there
talking [ __ ] [ __ ] it up for everybody
else i'm kidding
um yeah this is the time of night i
still feel like getting [ __ ] up
what time is it right now oh 9 51. kids
are in bed
you know finish the podcast it's that
time of day
when you can say come on and head
for the mountains the taste is smooth
with 27 shots of booze
um but i'm not gonna do it oh jesus
christ
you know i did a gig recently and these
people sent me a bottle of whiskey
backstage
you know and i was just looking at it
going you know i remember a time
i'd finish half of that
i wouldn't feel good the next morning
but the time i had drinking it oh that
would be fun all right let's stop
reminiscing about mistakes i made
all right that is the podcast everybody
all right
um enjoy the olympics i think it's great
that russia showed up
anyway you know
and that evidently japan was too afraid
to tell them to go hump
it makes no sense but i do like that
like well hey man i didn't do drugs
right i am a drug-free
ping-pong player what kind of [ __ ]
drugs do
you know i don't understand some of
these some of these [ __ ] sports you
know
like like nobody's on drugs
no i mean it's okay skateboarders are on
drugs but not to enhance
skating doesn't make you a better skater
right
they're just on drugs
really bill are you going to perpetua i
am god damn it they're all over the
[ __ ]
office park
i'm kidding i've never had a problem
with skateboarders it's funny when you
drop back in the day when you would
drive up the street
and they'd be out on the street and they
would just be looking for a fight it's
like dude
skateboard i'm i'm they had skateboards
when i was a kid
okay i'm not this isn't like whatever
[ __ ] dog town and z
boy movie you read okay i i was on those
things i know what it feels like to fall
off one of those [ __ ] things all
right
i built the ramps i fell down i scraped
my [ __ ] knees and elbows i bang i
know what the sound of my head hitting
the [ __ ]
asphalt sounds like all right i stuck
with
i stayed on the grass i got back on the
grass all right stop staring at me like
i'm [ __ ] hugh bulman
coming home all right that's it
everybody uh
enjoy the music picked out by andrew
thumbless and then we'll have a bonus
episode of the thursday afternoon just
before friday monday morning podcast
have a great weekend you [ __ ] and um
and really enjoying the swimming
and uh yeah i think that's all i just
you know i put it on at the same time i
just keep catching the swimming
and uh i wish they would do the overhead
view
more often of the race because not only
can you you can still see who's in the
lead but you can also see how
unbelievably fast they're going
like they're swimming fast enough that
like if they were a boat in
in like a harbor a little harbor area
you know those little little [ __ ]
things i'm not a boat guy you know
whether it's a speed you're supposed to
be going or you cause too much of a
little [ __ ]
wave you cause somebody's boat to bump
against the dock like that
you know if they were a boat they'd be
getting yelled at that's how fast
they're going
yeah bill it's the olympics well
whatever i was impressed they didn't
have that angle when i was a kid jesus
christ
you know go [ __ ] ride your skateboard
have a great weekend everybody see
hey what's going on it's bill burr and
it's the monday morning podcast
for monday uh july 29th
2013 how you doing um i'm on the road
right now i'm currently in new orleans
and i brought all my podcast stuff with
me but of course
i was kidding who i went to summer
school
i should have gone three out of the four
years i went to high school i should
have actually gone all four years
but uh one year my math teacher gave me
the d minus
and then my senior year was kind of like
well what's the [ __ ] point
but um for the record i should have gone
four times
um all four years and for those of you
listening overseas
basically summer school if you don't
have it over there is basically you
[ __ ] up so bad they gave you 10 months
to get your [ __ ] together
and evidently that wasn't enough for you
so no swimming
no biking no experimental drugs for you
and you have to go to [ __ ] summer
school so
um next week i will have a power cord
here i am in new orleans right now
and um i'm starting my acting gig i'm
going to be here
for the next couple two three weeks
so uh yeah
i hope these levels are all right i
don't know how to [ __ ] adjust them
on this garage band thing that's what
i'm recording it um
yeah you know it's it's the usual
[ __ ] i just i just don't get along
with technology
um i like to think i didn't start it
maybe i did
maybe i did start it by just you know
you know what my problem was i thought
it was just a fad
you know i thought computers and in this
new technology and [ __ ] i just thought
it was some i just
i looked at it as an extension to video
games i looked at it and it was just a
time
sponge i don't want to do that [ __ ] i
want to go out and go [ __ ] do
something
you know and uh
you know i i think we can say at this
point that i was wrong i remember when i
was living with bobby kelly
[Music]
check out when new laptop dude it weighs
47 pounds dude
um back in 1995 or 96 or whatever the
[ __ ] we lived together and he was he he
just
jumped all over that ship and what was
funny
is i was smarter than bobby kelly in
and 18 years later
he is way smarter than i am because
my just i just i don't there's just
something right out right up right out
of the gate that i just did not like
about computers i just didn't like it
you know i remember back in high school
when they had like the [ __ ] piece of
paper was coming out of the things and
you know you had to you know what what
the [ __ ] computer programming
i was just sitting there like i would
rather dig for fossils
than [ __ ] sit here another minute
typing in run enter whatever the [ __ ] we
were doing
and it was it was not fun on any [ __ ]
level
so anyways i'm not gonna let you i mean
i wasn't
ever really that smart but i wasn't a
[ __ ] [ __ ] but
my lack of embracing computers
i feel like in an odd way i've gone from
being literate to completely [ __ ]
illiterate
uh i get unbelievably frustrated with
them and uh you know i do you know i do
with my computer a lot
i grab it i pick the [ __ ] thing up
and and i hold it over my head like
[ __ ] hulk hogan when he's gonna slam
a chair against somebody's [ __ ]
sweaty back
and i bite my bottom lip now i never do
it because it costs so much [ __ ]
money but i swear to god
one of these times i just want to do it
once just one time but i know
instantly i'll regret it but um i just
i apologize for the the poor quality of
this podcast so i'm going to try to
speak
in regular speaking tones i won't do my
usual [ __ ] with the microphone
which is my crutch to make this podcast
remotely entertaining
and also i'm in a i'm in a hotel room
and if those of you who've listened to
my podcast for a long time remember when
i was stuck in new jersey
during that [ __ ] hurricane or
whatever the hell was going on and i was
a little too loud and security came i
don't feel like doing that all right
it's one thing if i'm out on the road
and i'm just doing a comedy gig who
gives a [ __ ]
right i'm a i'm a made guy
in strip mall comedy clubs so i can piss
off the front desk but as far as this
acted [ __ ] goes i'm a newbie
so i don't feel like uh i don't feel
like uh you know
screwing things up right out of the gate
so i'm going to try to behave myself
as much as humanly possible um
but i was also thinking you know i want
to get better at computers and i also
want to
does does that sound dumb am i even
saying that wrong i want to be
good computer i will do do computer
better
um complete [ __ ] you know
something what does it say about you
that you're actually [ __ ] listening
to this you know i i don't know why
you're listening to why why
at this point you really should hit stop
and [ __ ] delete it or whatever but
you know i'm not here to tell you what
to do
so anyways uh i'd like to become
more proficient when it comes to the
computer sciences
is that how i'm supposed to say it oh
give us a [ __ ]
um and also i would i would like to quit
[ __ ] around
on the computer i found out the other
day you need like 40
50 hours that's all you need 40 50 hours
and you'll know how to fly a plane
i mean you got the classroom [ __ ] too
but as far as just like learning how to
fly the [ __ ] thing
somebody told me the other day i don't
know i was talking about the motorcycle
license thing i was gloating that i
finally [ __ ] got one
and uh you know what's [ __ ] hilarious
is i'm actually afraid to go out and go
ride a bike down the street whatever i
got one
i got him i got i got the [ __ ] thing
so this person was telling me that they
uh
that they had a pilot's license now it's
[ __ ] cool thing to do and i was like
how many hours and he said well by 10
hours in you can pretty much fly the
[ __ ] thing he goes obviously
you know you could hurrifically screw up
but you're proficient enough where you
could get yourself
up off the ground before you flew into
the side of somebody's silo
but uh and i was just that just has been
sticking with me all week
that if i spent 10 hours doing that i
would actually you know
if god forbid i was ever on some [ __ ]
doing some hell gig
where i'm flying one of those [ __ ]
planes with you know in one of those
planes with like the water skis
and the guy has a [ __ ] aneurysm and i
got 10 hours out of my belt i could
[ __ ] crawl up there
you know you'll be funny about that is
you'd actually have to sit on the guy's
lap
if it was a really cramped little ass
plane with like the one seat and [ __ ]
you'd have to do that you'd have to push
through
whatever your level of homophobia is you
know
depending you know depending if he had
it on on automatic pilot which i i don't
even know if you had do you have that
option on one of those little [ __ ]
planes
what's the deal with planes i mean are
they just like cars
where you can buy the ford escort of
planes why the [ __ ] would you do that
hey do you want the uh you want the rust
proofing ah that's fine
let's i'll just take it as i'll buy
right off the lot thank you
um vinyl interior anyways
so i was just thinking how much time i
spend just wasting
you know watching people getting kicked
in the balls
all the porn i have to sift through to
find something that even remotely turns
me on at this point
because i've watched so much of that
[ __ ] [ __ ]
you know the last porno i watched i
actually apologized to the three women
that were in it when i was done
i swear to god you know i was just like
ah jesus christ what am i i'm sorry
ladies i'm sorry your dad didn't stick
around i
uh it was just dreadful yeah whatever
you'll see it someday if i ever decide
to run for president you know and if i
if i don't
fall in line the [ __ ] nsa will hey
this is what he jerks off to
um anyway you know some you know what's
pissing me off is the amount of people
who aren't supporting that snowden guy
i think there's a lot of people i'm
going to go on a limb here and i'm going
to say there's a lot of people that
don't like getting spied on
you know think it's completely
unnecessary
and think that and view that snowden guy
as a whistleblower not as some sort of
traitor
but you you just know that you can't say
that you can't say that [ __ ] on tv
and uh that's not a 911 thing that's a
[ __ ] post-vietnam thing
i was thinking about that the other day
where they had everybody was singing
songs saying you know
protesting against the war not saying
whether it was right or not
but you could do that back then and you
didn't get that dixie check
treatment you know that [ __ ] where they
were like well
they had the right to sing it and we
have the right to disapprove
of it it's like yeah yeah you do
say i didn't appreciate that [ __ ] them
but when you take it to the level you
try to systematically destroy
their ability to make to earn a living
then uh
you know that's not tit for tat that's
like hey i threw a rock at you
and you dropped the [ __ ] bomb on me
hey bill why don't you get to some
topical material from this [ __ ]
decade all right sorry
um the hell was i talking i don't know
what i was talking about
i got so self-conscious that i was
somehow talking about the dixie oh yeah
yeah back in the day you could you could
[ __ ]
you know you could say uh you know
you could say things that it wasn't all
tied into
you know supporting troops and loving
babies and uh
being pro ice cream and against the
terrorists it's like it's [ __ ] uh
it's really childish it's a really
childish era
that we're living it and it's gradually
seeping into
what it is that i do for a living where
there's these complete
uh nincompoops can i use that word that
are deciding to go to comedy shows
and take jokes seriously
i mean how old are you i i can't i can't
um
what are you gonna do next go to the
circus and watch the clown hit another
clown with a rubber hammer and
that's promoting violence he could get a
concussion
no more rubber hammers at the circus and
what the [ __ ] is wrong when you grow up
you know what i mean i love how they
think that like comedians
have this this [ __ ] level of power
that they're gonna do a
joke okay and that people in the crowd
are so
[ __ ] stupid that that's gonna form
their world view you know
like if i did a joke that was like pro
chopping somebody's [ __ ] hand off i
are you really telling me that there's
people out there that are so
[ __ ] stupid that they're gonna walk
into a comedy show before they walked in
they had no desire to do it
and felt that doing that to another
human being was a terrible
thing to do but then once i make a joke
about it
all of a sudden there's going to be a
bunch of people walking around chopping
people's hands off
because i joked about it it's it's it's
unbelievably [ __ ] childish and it's
condescending
and uh i don't know i just keep seeing
more and more
of that type of [ __ ] um by the way for
people get up in arms about some of
those jokes
uh that one because i don't want to feed
the fire here but you know that one
topic that you're talking about
also can happen to a man you know so
i don't know why you feel like it's it's
just yours
i was actually joking about that on
stage i'll burn the bit
one gives a [ __ ] you know what it is at
least when it happens to them people
give a [ __ ]
if it happens to a guy they people
literally think it's funny
they laugh you know i remember when that
dude got his dick cut off
by his wife he was cheating on his wife
and she cut his dick off and she threw
it in the garbage disposal and turned it
on
and it was one of those shows that was
ripping off the view it's the one that
has the asian
lady i don't even know if it's still on
but they were talking about it and they
were snickering
you know what i mean it was [ __ ]
funny to them it's horrific if it was
they found humor in it so
i i don't know i i don't know what the
[ __ ] i'm talking about anymore
let's let's do a little little
advertising here uh
i'm sorry about the clicking of the uh
whatever this [ __ ] button is called
i'm sure bobby knows what it's called i
bet he's
i bet he has some the latest one dude i
got the latest [ __ ]
steve job [ __ ] spacebar thank you
um i said it bobby kelly's smarter than
me
we're actually doing a two-man comedy
show off off-broadway called bobby kelly
smarter than me it's kind of like a
george burn uh sunshine boys
type of thing by the way robert kelly if
you guys were up in canada
i heard he murdered it up at the
montreal comedy festival
all right but enough about that [ __ ]
let's talk about the dollar shave club
everybody
dollar shave shave club um it's a cool
brand i hate how they do this has made
me so much happier about shaving no it
hasn't okay it's [ __ ] convenient
i totally recommend it stop putting
[ __ ] words in my mouth
anyways dollar shave club everybody
has made my life way more convenient
um it's a cool brand and they send you
quality razors right to your door every
month
you don't have to think about it you
don't have to wait in line you don't
have to get someone to unlock that cage
for you like they're taking out a bar of
gold
you don't have to pay way too much money
for a bunch of features that don't even
fit on your old handle
all right shaving has become such a mess
okay it's a complete rip
off all right there's snake oil salesman
it's a little plastic piece of crap with
with so
like it's not even aluminum i don't know
what it is in there
okay it's a piece of crap and they've
been charging you
an arm and a leg for it well who's
coming to the rescue dollar shave club
all right i want you to go out and try
it i dare you to try this product and
tell me you're not satisfied with it
what do you think about that
see that advertisers i don't need you to
write words for me
um well this part i do support this show
go to dollar shave club forward slash
burr
or click bur click or click on the
dollar shave club banner on the podcast
page at billboard.com
all right then you don't have to deal
with it you don't have to deal with it
anymore
no more standing in line for one of
those old people you know
going to some understaffed cvs trying to
find somebody who actually can walk away
from the cash register
slash like ice cream you know what's
funny old people buy ice cream in like
pharmacies you know they don't care
they don't need it to be hog and dust is
there dairy in there
is it cold well put it on a cone you
[ __ ] [ __ ]
all right ah sorry most of this rage has
to do with the fact that i feel like an
idiot that i didn't bring the power
strip thing or whatever it's not a power
strip
the plug-in thingy that goes into the
back of the doohickey
um all right so now you don't have to
buy um you don't you don't have to worry
about buying uh
uh what do you call blades for your
shaver
shaving blades is that what they're
called i don't know wouldn't it be nice
if you didn't have to deal with that you
also didn't have to go to the post
office
well why don't you go to stamps.com you
know
quit staring at the lamp grab the reins
or your life all right postage meter
companies used to have a monopoly on
printing postage
they could charge you an arm and a leg
to print postage from your own office
but those days are over over
like michael corleone said corleone is
that what he's lana
now you can use stamps.com instead with
stamps.com get all the benefits of a
postage meter but at a fraction of the
cost
all you need is your computer your
printer and stamps.com to get
to get official us postage for any
letter or package
any class of mail it's so damn
convenient plus you'll never have to
step foot inside of a crowded post
office again
all right this is your whole saturday
morning right
paying your bills driving down to the
post office standing in line and then
you go over to cvs to buy you shaving
blades you don't need to do this anymore
all right get with the times man
everything you do at the post office you
can do right from your desk it's so
convenient
all right i use stamps.com to send out
all my merch for when i [ __ ] myself out
after my shows
and you guys know how dumb i am so if i
can do it anybody can do it
right now use my last name bur for this
special offer
no risk trial plus 110 bonus offer that
includes a digital scale and up to 55
free postage what more do you need don't
wait go to stamp store
dot com before you do anything else
click on the microphone at the top of
the home page
and type in bur b u r r that stamp stop
com
enter bur all right back to the podcast
and i apologize for the click
um all right where the hell am i here
um oh this is what i did before i came
to new orleans
i um i did the first leg of the
billy red state tour with uh limited
edition t-shirts
and these are limited editions they're
only going to be sold on the red state
tour
unless i don't sell all of them at which
point they'll be available to everybody
you see that that's called honesty and
advertising
um but anyways i got i went to boise
idaho
and uh then i drove up to bozeman
montana it was like this
unbelievably great like seven eight hour
drive could have done it in six but you
know we were stopping along the way me
and uh
lucas sealy comedian i met back in the
day when i used to do uh this guy's room
uh
giggles comedy club that no longer exist
exists sadly it was such a great club
and uh i love that club owner man he was
such a character
you know the first weekend i work with
this guy he came out
and gave me a shoe box full of like
fives tens ones like was my money for
the week
it was thinking that i was just gonna
have that under my arm and go
walk through [ __ ] airport security
and not look like a [ __ ]
like i was dealing crack you know
i still remember it was one it was one
of those boxes that you put baseballs in
and he had all he had the piece of paper
to say how many comps there were he had
all the information he had it in a
shoebox
and it looked like it looked like he was
trying to raise money
for kidney dialysis you know or maybe he
was playing the banjo
on the sidewalk and everybody just threw
money in there every which way
and uh i don't know back then i hadn't
read about banks today i probably would
have taken it i would have counted it
out
i would have taken it but then at the
end of the day it's just a piece of
[ __ ] paper
um so anyways i but it was such a great
room
and i had so many fun uh shows when i
was there and uh along the way i met you
know a bunch of great companies they had
a great scene there in seattle i hope
they still do
um i haven't been there in a minute but
i met this dude
lucas sealy so we did uh boise idaho the
first night
which was right on the campus of boise
state university for some reason i i
didn't realize that that's where i was
performing
and uh it was phenomenal i took video
um i couldn't get into the stadium but i
was in the corner of the end zone i saw
a little bit of that iconic
blue turf and i know a lot of people
from the bigger schools
will give me [ __ ] for calling an iconic
well [ __ ] you
all right and your goddamn [ __ ]
your school songs that all sound the
same
you know
[Music]
the same guy write all of those [ __ ]
songs um
and those are the only three that you
know right the lsu when i recognize it
when i hear it
um you know it's funny being down here
in new orleans i keep forgetting i'm
here
so every time i see an lsu shirt i like
light up and i'll be like hey
lsu huh lsu i i keep stopping myself
from saying that
that'd be like in boston but hey red sox
right red sox
oh by the way i'm slowly i'm back into
baseball
i don't know what happened i just been
on the road and i've been watching games
and i've been watching like
the uh i've been watching the half nuts
you know been watching the royals been
watching the indians who actually are
the haves they just can't
hang like hang on to their guys
um i've already given you that theory
why they should have an honest honorary
world series
[ __ ] trophy you know phillies the
yankees the red sox we all
stole all of their [ __ ] guys didn't
steal them but whatever you know what it
is
um i use them as a farm team it's
[ __ ] i like them i like the indians
i like the
royals i like the pirates i like the uh
the devil rays well they lost some
points by calling themselves the rays
that's another childish [ __ ] thing
how old are you
devil rage that's evil it's gonna make
kids evil
you know why don't you just call them
the [ __ ] how about that would that be
you know
the the tampa bay uh after you
why don't you just call it that no no no
no you you eat the last slice
the the just
i don't know the tampa bay it was a
pleasure meeting news
use i'm sorry anyways let's get back to
this [ __ ] so i um
both shows i don't know what was what
got into me i i hadn't done stand up in
a minute i've been busy
uh writing some other [ __ ]
and um i did two of the launch
i think the two longest sets i've ever
done i did like 90 minutes
and i never do that you know because i
watched the comedian one time do two
hours and i was sitting in the crowd and
right at an hour i started looking at my
watch and by like an hour 25 my ass
was falling asleep so i apologize to
people in boise and bozeman
i was just having a great [ __ ] time
and i was really excited about coming up
there
and uh it did not disappoint that drive
from boise
to bozeman montana you owe it to
yourself to do that and go through
you know what killed me is i didn't have
the time i didn't have the time to go
see the evil knievel thing and i didn't
have the time to go into yellowstone but
you know i kind of
took this uh highway that went right
along yellowstone and it was absolutely
[ __ ] beautiful i saw wild horses
you know granted they were on a reserve
i took a picture and you could see the
fence but
they had a completely different [ __ ]
attitude
than those horses that you know you go
down and ride across the [ __ ] street
on you know
they hadn't been broken they still had
the light in their eyes you know
those other ones are like the ones you
know in the [ __ ] cubicles
they're in the matrix somebody on their
[ __ ] back you know
the mustangs though you know those are
the guys those are guys uh
they're off the grid so anyways i saw
them and then there was
there was some place where you could
look at bears i love bears but i'm you
know i'm also not a [ __ ]
so two things one i don't want to see
one that's wild and i don't want to see
one in a [ __ ] cage
i'll just watch him on tv and they had
this they had the place where you could
actually look at him
and it was the worst [ __ ] name what
would you do if you had a bear sanctuary
just just for me what would you call it
i'll give you five seconds to come up
with the name and i guarantee you it's
better than what the [ __ ] they called it
bear world you know
jesus [ __ ] great was
is anybody creative in your [ __ ]
circle
of business part partners we'll call it
bear world
you know there's bears and
you know they've been the world so bear
world
i own a number of businesses i sell yarn
down the street
yarn world own galaxy was
was a choice i was gonna make you
[ __ ] [ __ ] i couldn't even stop there
bear world you know i should go in there
there should be somebody in a [ __ ]
bear suit
you know except it's not a joke he's
actually trying to [ __ ]
pull it off like he really is a bear you
know
if you're dumb enough to stop off at a
place called bear world but
i did have a good time in other places i
went to this uh
i stopped off at this diner it was
actually a drive-in diner
like [ __ ] happy day [ __ ] but they
weren't on roller skates
and uh he could pull right up but i
still want i went in i wanted to see the
the place you know um
see the pictures on the walls and all
that type of stuff and i i got a double
cheeseburger there
with tater tots and a root beer and i
have to tell you set the man it was
[ __ ] delicious you know it was even
better
it was a high quality piece of greasy
meat
because i didn't feel sick afterwards i
felt a little like uh why the [ __ ] did i
do that
you know as you're gonna when you do
something like that but uh
i i feel like they had a better quality
burger than you usually find in some
you know a place like that i'm gonna
give them a shout out here what the [ __ ]
was it called
it's called frost top drivin
in idaho uh it's been open since 1965
and i don't know if you ever wanted to
just drive up
and not have to get out of your car and
consume 4 000 of the most delicious
[ __ ] calories you ever had in your
life
i highly recommend them it was
tremendous
and uh i'm a big fan of root beer
i love it but i don't [ __ ] with soda
because uh you know
i know what it does to you but that's
that you know every once in a while when
i hit the crack pipe that's what i get
i get one of those [ __ ] either get
one of those or
if i can get one of the uh out in la
they have uh
they have the the the orange crush that
actually has real sugar in it
and it tastes like the [ __ ] when it when
it first came out in the late
70s orange crush
like put make it like put you in a
better mood
that's how good it [ __ ] tasted ah
jesus those were the [ __ ] days
you know no stress no [ __ ] i had a
[ __ ] paper route
right i've had a job since i was in the
third grade
just thinking that the other day i had
that paper from third grade
to ninth grade to the point it was
getting weird you know
like my voice was changing and i'm like
hey how you doing uh
yeah only uh 260 for the week uh was it
what was it for the week seven dollars
725 no no no it's like 260 for the week
and then if it was three weeks i
remember be like seven dollars and
something cents and i would be nervous
that the dad was going to answer and be
[ __ ] pissed
um i still remember this time this
person owed me 11
25 or something i finally got him when
they were home they were just never
[ __ ] home and i finally got him
and the guy actually laughed i still
remember it he had this wood stove
and he had the [ __ ] thing cranking
and it was freezing out and i was
collecting
i always hated collecting i like i swear
i've always been such a [ __ ] loner
that's probably why i do this podcast by
myself
i i i just like the delivering the of
the [ __ ] papers
i loved it riding my bike talking to
myself
you know i used to ride around my bike
and i would i would be doing [ __ ]
carlin in prior bits that i had
memorized pretending i was doing in
front of the class
and i was still too [ __ ] stupid to
realize that that meant that i wanted to
be a comedian
i was a [ __ ] anyways i still remember
that at 11 25
my bill for the week was like i don't
know like 18 bucks maybe
and i got 11.25 off of this house and i
had like 30 something customers
so i was [ __ ] rolling in it you know
i didn't have a mortgage you don't have
a mortgage and you don't have rent
and you don't have a woman in your life
and you got like 22 bucks
right you know the [ __ ] car you
you're a millionaire
so i went up to the local store what did
i did i invest my money
did i save it up no i went down there
and i bought a bunch of football cards
in a [ __ ] giant orange crush
and i sat right on the store opened all
of them sticking a [ __ ]
that awful piece of gum that always
tastes like [ __ ]
but you just you had to put it in there
there's more sugar just shove that thing
in my [ __ ] mouth it was like
covered with like i it's like it's like
someone was plastering a wall
you know that [ __ ] when it comes down
and it gets your eyebrows and [ __ ]
that's what was like on the gum
i just sat there
that's all i did it was like one of the
great [ __ ] days
of my life so every once in a while if i
find an orange crush and it actually has
the real sugar
you know you know that sensory sense
memory [ __ ]
i [ __ ] drink that goddamn thing and
i'm back out in front of that store
nobody's [ __ ] with me it's just me
and my little bicycle oh a little billy
red freckle face
anyways the [ __ ] am i talking about oh
you know what i did
i came up with a good nickname for lucas
sealy everybody
lucas silva you know you're driving a
car with somebody for [ __ ] eight
hours you just start talking about
everything
and uh he was talking about playing high
school football and everything and i
don't know why i just started thinking
chris berman what chris berman would
call him and i came up with his chris
berman nickname of
uh what was it
lucas now you seely now you don't
and i was doing i know it's corny but it
was great in the car ride
because i was doing the whole thing with
chris berman going now you seely and
then i was doing
tom jackson yelling now you don't and
then i would do that
like he just made a [ __ ] move and we
were we were having the time of our
[ __ ] lives
i swear to god i wish all you guys could
just do something on the road once
you gotta [ __ ] do it you know
why don't you just accidentally like do
something to the building that you're
working
you know nothing crazy just [ __ ] make
make one of the [ __ ] pipes
you know the pipe where the [ __ ] goes
out just [ __ ] that thing up that's some
osha [ __ ] there's no way you'd have to
come in
ah what could you do in a day though i
don't know i drove from boise to bozeman
hey you know what it's your [ __ ] life
i don't have time to figure it out you
guys figure it out
um what the hell am i talking about here
so anyways i'm trying to look here oh so
i'm in new orleans and i'm going to try
to be a good boy when i'm down here i'm
going to try to not drink
staying away from bourbon street and all
those [ __ ] animals down there
that tits out walking around this
sunburned [ __ ]
areolas i don't want to look at that
[ __ ] i'm too old for it
i can't do it anymore you know um oh
wait i didn't finish telling the story
so i went all the way up i know i'm all
over the map [ __ ] you all right
um once again sorry for the clicks here
i have to see where i'm at
31 how can you hear those people in the
hall
oh you know i was staying when i was in
uh
boise i was tired as [ __ ] i was staying
in this uh
when i stayed i stayed in the west end
and the best western i didn't know what
the [ __ ] it was
and uh it's one of those things that
looks like a hotel but it's not a hotel
but but it's not a motel it's kind of a
little bit of both
it's like you're inside but i don't know
it's just kind of flimsy doors and like
the other side
went out you know one side goes to the
hall the other side
is a glass door that they have these
flimsy curtains and you open it up in
the [ __ ] pools there
so i'm tired and all i want to do is
just take a nap before the [ __ ] show
and there's a bunch of kids in the pool
you know playing games and screaming and
yelling and [ __ ] and you know which i i
can tolerate
um but they started running up and down
the halls
you know how you're excited as a kid
your hotel pool and all that [ __ ] you
run everywhere you [ __ ] go i swear to
god
by the time like the [ __ ] ninth kid
ran down the hall i was having these
fantasies of
quickly opening the door and just
clotheslining one of these kids
and uh yeah so one of the reasons why i
probably should never be a father
because i
have really violent thoughts like that
um
you know i had one at the airport when
i'll sit there i flew
alaska airlines up to boise and uh
they didn't offer that skycap service
you know
so i had to go into the the airport with
all the animals
okay life is all about making enough
money
so you can buy your way out of the out
of the pig pen
you know when you go to the airport the
pig pen is right in
on the other side of that [ __ ] glass
if you ever if you have a bag that
you're checking
but even then even if you even if you
just have a carry-on you're gonna have
to deal
with how [ __ ] stupid people are
you're just gonna have to d you're gonna
be standing behind somebody
and you're just going to deal with how
[ __ ] stupid they are so i would
rather
you know just [ __ ] pay just
walk stand in the [ __ ] line outside
have this guy hey how are you mr burr
how's it going i'm it's going great tip
of the hat is [ __ ] a bunch of you
know here's some money
good for you you know thank you he
is a great [ __ ] tip for keeping me
out of the pig pen
god bless you that's how i look at it
right so i show up alaska they don't
have
you know they don't offer that which
right there's a [ __ ] red flag it's
like
okay you can't afford to pay those guys
you know
you're gonna have enough gas in the
plane you're gonna have it on half a
tank the whole way up trying to make it
up your [ __ ] dicks so anyway so i
walk in there and it's just a complete
i'm actually writing a blog about it
it's really dark and evil
and i'm gonna put it up on all things
comedy um
i'm gonna finish it uh in the next
couple days or so but
long story [ __ ] short is it's a
complete cluster [ __ ] when you go in
there
and they have one employee they have two
lines they have one employee for every
for two lines you know one employee's
working like two lines
and everybody's huffing and puffing
looking at their watches wondering why
it's taking so [ __ ] long and then
when they get up there and it's their
[ __ ] turn
they're not ready to go they're like
thurman thomas they don't have their
[ __ ] helmet
they're in the huddle without their
[ __ ] helmet and i swear to
[ __ ] god i swear and
then what i do is i just start muttering
every [ __ ] curse word
every [ __ ] curse word i can play and
someone's always looking at me like like
i'm like i'm the [ __ ] guy
who has the problem these [ __ ] idiots
they'll stand they'll stand like in a
security line
shaking their heads about how [ __ ]
long it's taking
and then when they get up there when
it's their moment
they're not ready to go let me help you
guys out here
not all of you but but just for the
[ __ ] morons
okay and you should really take that as
an insult someone as dumb as me calls
you a [ __ ] [ __ ]
when you stand in line okay
you have all this [ __ ] time to take
off all the [ __ ] that you're gonna have
to take off
if you got a jacket just shove it in the
pockets zip them up
you got your watch in there you got your
loose change you got all your [ __ ]
metals in there
okay you can undo your belt that's ready
to go
you know have your shoes ready to slip
off
mentally think how many bins do i need
okay
[ __ ] have a game plan you get up
there
you grab the binge you need you [ __ ]
put them flush
up with the person in front of you you
put all your [ __ ] in them
and when the person moves up in front of
you you [ __ ] move your [ __ ] too
all right and that would cut down so
much eye rolling in your [ __ ] life
standing in those lines you know this is
just a waste it's a waste of time
it's a waste of [ __ ] time because
people aren't gonna get it
they're not going to get they stand in
line and these [ __ ] tsa guys
go over and over and over if you have
any liquids if you have a laptop if you
have
shoes if you have this that does
and they say it 900 times and it drives
me [ __ ] nuts i used to hate them for
saying it 50 times going
why the [ __ ] do you keep saying that and
then i just watched people in front of
me
is it okay to have toothpaste and a big
gulp
what i took off one shoe is that okay
like that [ __ ] i actually have empathy
for them now
um there's another thing too when you go
on these small mom and pop airports like
the one i flew out this morning in
bozeman montana
it was so small my [ __ ] um map app
whatever the [ __ ] you call it the steve
jobs map app
they couldn't even find it it took me to
somebody's house
oh you want to hear cursing when the
sun's coming up over those beautiful
mountains
you know people probably thought they
had a bear in their front yard that's
how [ __ ] upset i was
um anyways
let's just get back to some happy [ __ ]
so i go we drive up to bozeman montana
and
it's [ __ ] absolutely gorgeous
and uh actually promised him that i
wouldn't tell him how nice it was
so people wouldn't go up there
so i broke my promise i apologize to the
people up there but it was [ __ ]
beautiful
i'm so i have to say it was [ __ ]
gorgeous and
i ended up doing an hour and like 40
minutes
so if your ass fell asleep i apologize i
won't be doing that
uh i usually try to keep it to about an
hour an hour and 10 minutes
i broke the cardinal rule of leaving
them wanting more
but i there was something about the
crowds like i felt like uh
you know they were psyched
that i i made the trek up there so i did
an extra long show and i was psyched to
be up there and i played two really
really cool theaters
and i'm definitely going to come back
didn't sell out either one
which of course i love because that
motivates me
all right now i got to get this area
that's like what the south used to be
for me i couldn't [ __ ]
you know i couldn't sell any tickets
down i just kept going and going and
going and going so i'm hoping the word
of mouth
will uh will spread out that way
the very least they'll look at the red
state tour and be like you know the
t-shirt
wonder who the [ __ ] that is and
hopefully i can come back and do it
again but um
because right now i'm supposed to be in
deadwood south dakota
and i would have had the experience of
driving all the way across montana
into south dakota which is something i
really want to do
and uh oh last week speaking of
motorcycles evidently that's the [ __ ]
place to ride a motorcycle i've never
seen so many motorcycles in my life
and pickup trucks and trailers um
i was saying to lucas like basically
that if uh
i think up there if you if you don't
have a four-door pickup truck with a
trailer and some sort of [ __ ]
dirt bike or four-wheeler on the back
that you you know i think you get gay
bashed up there right
isn't it
anyways um all right let's let's do a
couple more ads and we'll get into your
letters for this week
um what the hell is it sorry about the
clicking sorry about the clicking
okay legal zoom everybody most americans
don't have a will
but why that's really stupid to not have
a will
um because you know people you have
loved ones fighting over it and the
government comes in takes your stuff
bill why don't you just read the copy
you don't have a law degree you know
what you're right
i'll go with you on this one you don't
want the government you don't want the
government
you don't want government rules jesus
dictating what happens to your property
and
minor children oh jesus you got to put
your kids in there too
i leave my si uh my daughter to my
sister
so why procrastinate most people say too
expensive or too time consuming
uh my answer to that people is
legalzoom.com
too expensive you're going to love legal
zooms reasonable prices
too time-consuming you say most people
finish the online process in just 20
minutes and we're not take we're not
talking some fill in the blank form here
that's not what we're talking about your
will is state specific
and personalized based on your
information best of all
legalzoom has 12 years of experience
helping people with important legal
matters
it's national make it make a will month
sorry it's national make a will month
everybody energy
so don't wait any longer go to
legalzoom.com today and get 15 percent
off your last will
but this offer ends soon uh your last
will
yeah you're only gonna die once
whatever anyways or get a living trust
and you'll receive a poor overwill
absolutely free
to get your special discount offer be
sure to enter bur in the referral box at
checkout for wills powers of attorney
trust and more go to legalzoom.com
legalzoom can provide self-help service
but at your specific
uh direction or connect you with an
attorney but they are not
a law firm um this is actually something
that really isn't a joke
i gotta unfortunately have uh i've had
so many friends die in and out of this
uh business and obviously um
you know they were too young to go so a
lot of them didn't have wills
some did some didn't and the ones that
did it was
one less thing to worry about so you
know if you got people you care about
you really should do it
okay that's the end of my little uh left
turn there all right hulu plus everybody
i'm sure you've tried hulu.com but i
want to tell you about hulu plus
hulu plus lets you watch thousands of
hit shows anytime anywhere
streaming on your tv or go or on the go
with your smartphone or tablet
why stand in line or ride a train and
just stare at your feet
why do that you could be watching your
favorite shows on hulu plus
hulu plus is a great way to binge watch
your favorite shows
um i missed what am i saying didn't
what are they doing here why are you
telling me that i'm going to catch up on
this [ __ ]
stop writing [ __ ] for me to say here i
like hulu plus
okay i think you should get it i want to
get it you don't need to have me make up
stuff about stuff i'm not watching
anyways um that on hulu plus if you ever
decide to if i ever decide to watch all
of lost
hulu plus is the place for all that you
know i just realized i have to apologize
to hulu plus they're just using this as
a jump off point i'm supposed to put in
the shows that i'm watching on hulu plus
like an idiot i'm taking this literally
see this is why i didn't come up with
hulu plus because i'm a [ __ ]
but the people at hulu plus they are not
it's only 7.99 a month
7.99 for all the shows and movies you
can watch what more do you want
huh do they gotta show up and just give
you a tv or a smartphone
catch up on current shows binge on all
your old favorite
favorites and or catch a great movie you
can do it all at hulu plus
right now you can try hulu plus for a
couple of weeks for free
on me when you go to my podcast page
billboard.com and click on the hulu plus
banner or go to huluplus.com
billburr uh please make sure you use the
huluplus.com
bill so you get an extended free trial
and so that they know
that i sent you it helps us kids want to
do now instead of stuttering i'll just
slow down the sentence
it helps us keep up the lights what it
helps us keep the lights on and gives
you a better deal one more time for the
extended free trial
huluplus.com bill
all right is that it for the uh the
reads for this week
i think we got one more we'll space it
out okay here we go
oh by the way i want to talk about
something else here uh people keep uh
oh by the way that topic i actually i
just write out topics like i'm making a
set list just [ __ ] i want to talk about
and i tried to write down airport
etiquette
and before you laugh at me write it down
on your post it there
etiquette's one of those words i've used
a zillion times and i've read it
not a zillion times as you can tell i
don't read that much but i probably read
at least 500 times you think it would
stick in my [ __ ] hard drive at that
point
i tried to spell etiquette i knew i
didn't know how to spell it so i thought
all right i'll just give it a shot and
i'll be in the vicinity and the computer
be like oh are you trying to spell this
um i spelt etiquette
a t e-d-i-c-a-t-e and uh
other than underlining it in red the
computer had nothing had no
no uh didn't even say like ada cat
or something you know etiquette
e-t-i-q-u-e-t
all right uh oh two things
i had a question i'm in new orleans does
anybody know of a rehearsal put space
out here where i can play drums
you know they have drums already set up
and i can just rent something you know
something reasonable let me know because
uh
there's a lot of down time when you do
these things so and i don't want to be
getting in trouble
you know becoming billy po bowie fat
face down here because all the delicious
seafood that they
stick in a fry later and it tastes
awesome this [ __ ] city is great
but it's going to give you a heart
attack if you stay here for three weeks
so
i'm trying to you know i went to the
supermarket i bought some nanas and
apples
i'm trying to get a fridge in here i got
to do something
oh by the way somebody's uh you know
somebody sent me something
that was saying shaming fat people um
fat shame does not work um
but you know what i actually actually
had a couple people that said i've
actually motivated them
i had this guy today actually it made my
day this guy said listen to the podcast
you know and he took the good ribbing
that i was giving fatties out there and
he started eating one giant salad a day
and working out doing whatever hell he
was doing the guy went from like
220 something or 230 something
down he's down to 169
169 so uh bravo to you that made me feel
great to read that tweet
and uh you know who knows this could
turn into a great show
you know i'll do my biggest loser except
i won't be nice i'll just sit there i'll
come out
like a comedian i'll just have a
microphone i'll just trash you
every day i'll just sit there making fun
of you oh that would be too mean
i'd start off making i do it on a tough
love way
jesus christ what channel would that be
how high up on the [ __ ] dial would
that be
right there that no network's going to
touch that nobody under channel 700
would [ __ ] with that
maybe i'll just do it i'll do a web
series i'll do them on my own website
a freckled face production um
all right here we go letters for the
week serbian love
look at this see that you start learning
capitals around the world you start
getting
uh you start getting letters from people
this is great i love when i get uh
letters from people from countries i've
never been to serbia everybody do you
know what the capital is
i knew it two weeks ago but i haven't
done it in two weeks it's new knowledge
what the [ __ ] is it
that's not brought bratislava no
is it i'm an [ __ ] i'm sorry
yeah the serbs eat the brats that's how
i remembered it brought us lava
i think i don't know hey billy hill i
like that benny hill
um there's this girl who lives someplace
around my place
i like this guy he's being nice and
vague this sounds scummy already
got i like you sir um i don't know where
but i see her around every so often oh
you just don't know where she lives i
thought you were saying hey there's this
chick she lives somewhere around my
place i don't want to get into it but
let's just say
she sucked my dick in an establishment
that had a roof where you wouldn't get
wet if it rained
um the problems are number one i'm 15.
it sucks no it doesn't do it's great to
be 15. it's great to be 15.
you know you got a lot of freedom
um and so is she
okay so what's the problem jesus christ
what do you want to do with this girl he
goes we just finished elementary school
in serbia and we used to go to separate
grades
and number two i think i love her she's
really smart
beautiful and funny the usual and me
looks wise on a scale of one to ten
i'm slightly above five
jesus come on man all right first of all
my first piece of advice is sit up
straight
when i'm reading this to you come on man
we're gonna build you up by the end of
this
um five feet out tall
and i like to waste my time listening to
a 40 year old pasty fellow who complains
about his big head and overpopulation
my problem is we haven't ever had the
chance to properly introduce ourselves
to one another
i sometimes see her on the tram and wave
to her just to make sure she
acknowledges my existence that's good
dude you're in the game
you got your uniform on you got your
foot on the top step of the dugout
you're not in the batter's box yet
you're not even on the on deck circle
swinging the two bets but you're there
all right i like this okay you're making
positive moves here
okay so he goes i want to ask her i want
to ask her on a date
but i don't know her yet can you tell me
what to do
greetings from serbia come over sometime
so that we can kidnap you
[Laughter]
hey was that the place where uh
did that place used to be uh the the
country that
clinton bombed because he stuck that
cigar in that girl's [ __ ]
sorry about that you know
wouldn't that be [ __ ] ridiculous i go
over there and i take an ass kicking for
bill clinton
you know i just think the fact that my
name is bill that that that right there
that would be enough for them
but anyways all right so what is your
problem you want to ask her out on a
date well you wave to her
this is what i did yeah look you can't
just wave to somebody on the tram
and then just getting their grill and
ask them out you know this you gotta
like
because you kind of know her you know
what i mean look if you just meet a girl
on a train
you meet a girl on the train this is
what you do this is what i used to do i
would wait for somebody to do something
like some crazy person to get on
and they would do something [ __ ] up i
would hope that that would happen
because i i didn't have game to just
walk up and start talking to somebody
but in new york somebody always did
something [ __ ] weird
and then that when you know there's that
moment where somebody's doing something
[ __ ] up that
strangers look at each other like are
you [ __ ] kidding me and that's like
an opportunity to kind of maybe say
something funny
he's sitting next to him i sit across
from him like
i didn't have sitting across from you
game
who's getting who i didn't have a lot of
game why the [ __ ] are you asking me
um all right what would i do here all
right so you're doing that why don't you
uh why don't you properly introduce
yourself
start chatting with her you know and
don't
introduce yourself tip in your hand like
you're going to ask her out like hello
my name is lawrence serbia junior
uh you know getting down on one knee
just say what's up to her shoot the [ __ ]
with her make a [ __ ] laugh
you know you gotta you gotta get
yourself in her world
you know who knows she could be on the
other side
of that train going why is that [ __ ]
just waving to me
you know why doesn't he come over here
doesn't he know why that i'd like to uh
go to the serbian cineplex if it still
stands up
i was just picturing a bombed-out movie
theater that's like sort of a drive-in
but also has seats
i'm sorry i am the ugly american right
now you know what because you wrote me
to me i'm going to try and learn a
little bit more about your country
is that over there near uh bosnia and
in herzegovina huh
slovenia el julgen
the [ __ ] it is i don't know i i'm not a
lady i'm gonna be honest
eastern europe scares me for that exact
reason there's there's like
i did you know what they should do
rather than just showing you
like they should in a geographical way
show you where all the countries
are and then also in everybody's country
they should
they should have kidnapped countries
cool countries cool but it's not worth
going
uh and this place sucks or what you know
what i mean they should group them up
like that
you know could get kidnapped here you
could have uh
weed you know you have your boogie board
stolen and replaced with weed and now
you're gonna get [ __ ] put to death
where's that in bali
um i don't know that's what i would do
all right
i think it's great that you're actually
uh
you know waving to this girl and
everything this is a great thing about
women they're all right with you
if you're a five if you have a
personality
okay if you're you know what's great
thing about being a five
is you weed out all the stuck up [ __ ]
because they're not gonna [ __ ] with you
because you're a five and they're
you know they're materialistic and like
[ __ ] when they're in their teens
how they're materialistic because nobody
really has money
at 15 they're materialistic with
looks and as they get older what it ends
up being
is they you know those [ __ ] end up
going for the fives
the bald fat guys but they're going
after their money so this is the deal
you're a five you're probably not i bet
you're like
a strong seven if not an eight all right
you just got
i think you're being too hard on
yourself all right
so what am i trying to say here
if you're an average looking guy your
chances of meeting the sweetheart
are are much higher if you're the good
looking guy the quarterback on the team
or the [ __ ] playing soccer whatever
the [ __ ] you do over there
you know it's like you're a celebrity
you don't know which cheerleader is
going to blow you first and they're just
yeah
you don't know what's going on you know
but you have you actually you have the
kind of looks where you can actually sit
there
and from a distance fall in love with
somebody and pine for somebody
and wave to them on the train and then
be like oh where did they say something
you know what [ __ ] this you think you're
going to marry this girl
this is the this is the one you walk up
to this girl
and you get you get all your [ __ ]
awkward [ __ ] out of the way
learn how to talk to a woman with this
woman okay and keep those
those uh those skills sharp because one
day you know
when you do meet the love of your
[ __ ] life not saying this girl isn't
but if you do i
you won't be writing a dumb [ __ ] half a
world away
all right i hope that helped you out all
right last week i talked about tattoos
people who have inspirational sentences
written on their rib cage
um that's what i love when it's on the
[ __ ] rib cage where they can't even
read it so
it's like that's clearly for the rest of
us yes you've learned this lesson
and it's so important to you that you
have to turn yourself into a [ __ ]
post it
all right now i got a lot of a lot of
emails about this
a lot of people like defending their
paragraphs
you know some people saying look i had
hope
written on my arm and if i didn't if i
didn't see that every day that i i
that i would have forgot you know i
might be a [ __ ] i still understand why
you just can't write that down on a
poster i
have a post it right here i don't know
this is what i have
eat healthy practice drums no booze have
fun
giant salad every day if possible for
dinner
okay post it right on the mirror wake up
in the morning there it is
game plan i don't even have that written
on my [ __ ] rib cage
but then there was other people though
you know somebody had like never forget
they they were fighting over in iraq and
they lost a bunch of their buddies over
there i'm not talking about that [ __ ]
okay you know what i'm talking about i'm
talking about that stitching time saves
the [ __ ] book
you know it's not always the the rook
that queens the night sometimes it's the
pawn
whatever the [ __ ] you know that dumb
[ __ ] so
yeah i got a lot and i got a lot of uh
emails from women with feet tattoos that
uh no longer want to listen to the
podcast
um don't take the jokes too seriously
people
see this is the classic thing why you
can't take jokes seriously
you can't do it because people are
selfish that person with the foot tattoo
they laughed about all the fat [ __ ]
stuff unless they're a fat [ __ ] too
then they'd have a fat foot and a whole
they could have a whole mural
put on their chubby foot all right this
is this is a
a uh this is an email from a tattoo
artist he said bill just heard your
podcast where you talk about [ __ ]
getting their favorite
poem bible verse or inspirational quote
tattooed on them
i've been tattooing for 25 years and let
me tell you
this is the worst trend in tattooing yet
we all hate doing this [ __ ] i imagine
he's talking about the tattoo artist
at our shop we call the customers uh
that want this
that want this crap skin poets the
tattoos suck to do
it's like a school assignment and they
don't fit the shape of the body very
well
we get a lot of those spiritual yuppie
[ __ ] coming in and wanting something
they saw on a tiger woods poster
oh what like just do it um
no fear what are some of those dumb ones
they have
i hate those [ __ ] things you know
24 7. you know i hate those things
unless
a little kid's wearing them then they're
[ __ ] hilarious i saw a little kid he
had a shirt on that said
play me or trade me and i thought it was
[ __ ] hilarious
um but you know if you're an adult and
you gotta walk around with this is what
i do
on your t-shirt you yeah i don't know
um anyways he says he continues he says
you really want to read the same
paragraph over and over
i think it all started with megan fox i
guess she has [ __ ] written on her he
said i miss doing butterflies down by
the ass crack
uh love the show play for the white
sometimes and go
see we all like to go [ __ ] yourself dude
this guy literally
did not use any spaces
oh whatever i read it i read it well
enough well there you go that's from a
tattoo artist tattoo artists don't like
doing it
they call you skin poets so whatever
there you go skin poets
all right and i'm not talking about look
you know if
your dad died and you got something i'm
not talking about that [ __ ]
all right i'm talking about where you
gotta have some sort of you know
something deep man that's like uh
i don't know you know what i'm saying
i'm too dumb to [ __ ] even say what i
already said all right
bill this is from uh new zealand i
believe
this is great this uh this says you're
the only you're the only
ginger i do hey bill i'm a 31 year old
girl from new zealand
hey say what's up to phil rudd for me
will you
um anyways i stumbled across you
on youtube a while ago and i began
listening to you in the car
i like to drive along cracking up like a
nut case over the [ __ ] you say while
other drivers look at me and wonder why
i'm stoned
uh well this is why i do the podcast and
also to help my kids
uh she says i got my husband and kids
hooked on you too
no need to pay me for the publicity well
i hope they're not listening considering
you just told you said you'd [ __ ] me
um i'm sure you're just joking right
there you go just in case you're getting
[ __ ]
in case your husband plays for the all
blacks you know just gave you a [ __ ]
soccer knee to the face or is that rugby
they rugby
i don't know um i also want to share
uh with i also want to share with you
the fact that you are the only
fanta pants i never heard that i have
ever wanted to bang
so feel special
sweetheart do you realize how [ __ ]
condescending this is
you know as you sit out there on that
[ __ ] island in the middle of goddamn
nowhere
on the half of the planet that doesn't
do [ __ ]
on the other hemisphere was the last
time anybody from that hemisphere did
anything
jesus how many people am i pissing off
right now this has nothing to do with
that hemisphere has to do with this like
like i should feel [ __ ]
why are you acting like i put out a
personal ads that no one ever [ __ ] me
before
so feel special
what what the [ __ ] is wrong with you
i don't understand this new this that's
it's like it's happened since i started
doing this podcast where
all these like um this red i don't know
if it was underground
hatred of redheads or everybody watched
that south park episode you're a bunch
of hacks
and you're [ __ ] stealing off of their
jokes but i've had a tremendous [ __ ]
life
it's really i i never you know i guess
when i was younger when i had orange
hair
you know i felt like a [ __ ] freak and
i took the beat downs
yeah but once you're an adult i mean
what the [ __ ] sweetheart i don't need
sympathy [ __ ] from half a [ __ ] world
away
all right go [ __ ] yourself
i should feel privileged i don't know
what the [ __ ] you look like you know
what
kills me too about this this this
[ __ ] redhead hatred [ __ ]
the amount of [ __ ] people that i that
come up to me and
i'm i'm not even a good-looking guy i'm
better looking than they are i'm
embedded i have a
fat [ __ ] man titted
brown-haired dude coming up to me giving
me [ __ ] about having [ __ ] red hair
it's like dude have you looked at
yourself
how many [ __ ] mirrors do you need to
look at yourself you tub of [ __ ] look at
your [ __ ] nose
you know [ __ ] shark fin in the middle
of your goddamn face i got a great nose
i have a nice jaw i have beautiful blue
eyes i like myself
that's all i need all right lady i don't
need to go to new zealand
to get some [ __ ] on the side married
[ __ ]
jesus [ __ ] christ
anyways had to stop reading that
yeah that's another thing too i've had
me say mr like you're good looking for a
redhead
and i just want to say like you know
what you're not that good looking
for a for a person
yeah i i'm i've i'm fine with how i
[ __ ] look so you guys you don't you
don't need to have sympathy
i don't need i'm [ __ ] doing great all
right
thank you thank you for the uh trying to
cheer me up with
bestowing your your sacred [ __ ] on me
from
the other hemisphere um
that's unreal she lives in a country
australia makes fun of
okay she should be happy if a [ __ ]
warthog
climbs up her goddamn stairs they have
warthogs out there
um anyways all right let's
let's plow ahead here aggressive douche
hey bill i've been with my wife for six
years
and uh we've been married for one
congratulations he said when we first
started dating a guy
she knew turned up drunk on her doorstep
professing
his love for her oh jesus christ
jesus wow he said i wasn't mad
she's great and i couldn't blame him
well look at you having the empathy
i would just be looking like jesus
christ is bad enough when they bring up
an accident dinner forget about if the
guy shows up at your house
was he out there like john cusack with a
boom box over his head wearing a [ __ ]
trench coat
don't you forget about me what was that
song i never saw that say anything
i think i saw part of it i've always
been bored with the love story i'm
there's something wrong with me
anyways uh this means we've been well
i screwed up here oh she's great and i
couldn't blame him
um he goes on to say he was dating her
friend at the time though
and they are now engaged oh so he went
from
your now wife to banging
your now wife's friend and then realized
that he had a better thing
yeah jesus [ __ ] steamboat
all the sunburn tourists on there
all the po boys and [ __ ] local
the ipo ipa whatever the [ __ ] that is
all right we get it you're on a tom
sawyer boat who gives a [ __ ]
all right hey that's kind of nice i
shouldn't get mad at that that gives it
a a
maybe you guys thought i was lying that
was actually in my house
and uh i misplaced the court all right
there's no [ __ ] steamboats you know
many times i've been here and i just
found out that that's the mississippi
river
i know that i knew that the mississippi
river emptied out into the gulf here but
for some reason i thought it was on the
western side of the state
i don't know anyways let's plow ahead um
so anyways he was dating her friend at
the time though
and now they are engaged this means
we've been this means we've been for
drinks with this couple a few times
and they came to our wedding oh my god
you didn't put the kibosh on that
oh that's hard though right because
that's the ex but he's with
her friend oh god what did you see
you got to elope that's the way to do it
anyways he goes i'm pretty laid back
so i've been polite it was six years ago
now over the last year he started liking
her photos on
facebook pestering her when she's out
with the girls
oh now dude and trying to message her on
facebook he must know she would tell me
all this
so he did
wait he must know she would tell me all
this
so does he mistake my politeness for
weakness absolutely he does
he has a good woman already and i don't
want them to break up do i punch him in
the face
or smile as he ogles my wife thanks and
go [ __ ] yourself
from some dude no dude you need to
address this situation
yeah you gotta have you gotta have a
talk with the guy
um oh but wait but they're friends
this is what you do all right this is
one of these confrontations you got to
have in a public place
uh tell me you want to go out and have a
beer or
or grab a sandwich or something like
that
and uh go out and just sit down ask him
how he's doing and all that type of [ __ ]
and just say listen
uh you know
me and my wife are good friends with you
guys
and i'd like to stay that way would you
like it to stay that way and which point
you know
he's already gonna know what the [ __ ]
you're getting at and just say listen i
need you to uh
stop you know contacting my wife on
facebook
all right you want to hang out as a
couple
you know go on get some wine eat some
cheese tell some [ __ ] stories that's
fine
but uh you know
other than that you know you you need to
back off okay and i'm asking you this
one time politely
i'm not i didn't not saying anything to
anybody else i'm just telling to you
man-to-man
okay and uh
you know what what the [ __ ] he gonna
do
he can't go home and tell his wife that
you know that he's been you know
stalking your wife he can't do that
and um and make it even more
uncomfortable
and tell them that uh my wife knows that
i'm here saying this to you too
by the way so then it's that's it's just
a closed thing
all right you gotta nip that in the butt
because that is
that is the beginning of of
a creepy movie if you know what i mean
you know
i'm actually i actually got nervous
halfway through that giving you that
advice that's why i was saying get
into a uh public place you got to nip
that [ __ ] thing in the butt and i
would actually have a conversation with
your wife too
and say listen if uh
[Music]
this persists um we're not hanging out
with them as a couple anymore
okay because and if she gives you
you know why she's my friend and blah
blah blah
and just say honey i love you i need a
little empathy here
what if one of my exes came to the door
five years ago professing that she still
had a flame for me and still loved me
and all of that crap right and then was
stalking me and liking my photos on
facebook how would that make you feel
you know i'm not judging you but i
wouldn't put you in that position
okay you like that last sentence that
last sentence is called
game set match all right
uh walk hey bill big fan
and all that lapdog babble now you need
a new walk dude
i've been i've seen a bunch i'll go [ __ ]
yourself i need a new walk
you've watched all my specials on tv
well good for you
good for you thank you for doing that
jesus [ __ ] christ all right water
toxicity
hey bill water toxicity is the medical
term for when one's hiding oh this is
what i was talking about uh
what the [ __ ] was it um
that person what is it the the the they
drank too much water oh that's right
someone was asking me
you know how much water you can drink or
something like that you know what's
[ __ ] hilarious because the guy oh i
know the guy said he drank a gallon and
a half of water every day
and i was like dude be careful man you
drink too much water you could [ __ ]
die
and the amount of [ __ ] people that
wrote to me
telling me how much water you can drink
if 50 people wrote me they all had 50
different amounts
um so this person i don't know if this
is an actual doctor
or whatever said uh hey bill water
toxicity
is the medical term for one's hydration
uh when one's hydration reaches
dangerous and sometimes fatal levels
the actual mechanism at play is the
ratio of water
and electrolytes salt in one's body
okay you've already lost me what are
electrolytes is that that [ __ ] in
gatorade
uh the total amount of water one can
drink does not matter so long as the
amount of electrolytes are in balance
exercise and sweating depletes
electrolytes so it is
important to eat or mix in some gatorade
when rehydrating i was right
look at that ah jesus if this was a
multiple choice
[ __ ] test you know how dumb i am i
actually read half of that and when i
wasn't even
paying attention to it i got to gatorade
and snapped me back into it i just get
like
the second he goes scientific it's just
the total amount of water one can drink
does not matter
so long as the amount of electrolytes
are in balance ah
exercise and sweating depletes
electrolytes so it is important to eat
or mix in some gatorade when rehydrating
i didn't know that i used to eat a
[ __ ]
piece of fruit so i wouldn't get sick
when i sucked down the water
uh the woman that died at the at the
radio stunt drank
and didn't eat then reached fatal levels
oh so basically they could do that if
they had a bunch of gatorade
there anyways love the podcast my
girlfriend and i saw your one-nighter in
tampa a few months ago
and you were [ __ ] amazing thank you
thank you very much if you ever get a
chance
the flora georgia cocktail party game
in jacksonville is the pinnacle of sec
football is it i i gotta go to that
i'm gonna do that i'm gonna play the
comedy zone one uh
one of these years i'll do like a one
night or
i'll do like thursday friday and then
i'll be drunk on stage saturday because
i'm [ __ ] having a cocktail too
but uh i gotta tell you what i watched
on the plane coming down here
i watched that 30 for 30 again or maybe
it was an e60
it seemed like it was an hour long i
don't know on the alabama auburn rivalry
and that's one of my favorite
pieces of television ever
if you've never seen if you're not even
into sports you just have to watch
how insane that [ __ ] rivalry is
and there's a guy what the hell is his
name he has a radio show and i wanted to
ask
uh people who live in alabama who listen
to the podcast here i know i'm gonna say
his name wrong
is paul fine bomb or something that
radio show
is there any way i can get that can i
listen to it online
um can you give me like a link or
something i really want to listen to
that this year
as they're leading up i'm hoping
auburn's going to be good this year
um i know once cam left that they had a
little bit of a drop off but uh
i can't remember what they did last year
but um
i just want to listen to that [ __ ]
talking i i i
i was [ __ ] laughing my ass off
other than the maniac poison and
poisoning the trees which was just
ridiculous but like listening to those
people
with those southern accent just
yelling at each other and the amount of
passion it was just it was just
it was it's just [ __ ] phenomenal
phenomenal [ __ ] radio i have to uh i
have to somehow
figure out i have to go to that game not
only i got to go to that game but i have
to figure out
if i can't go i have to [ __ ] listen
to that like i've actually already
played it on my head one of these years
i'm gonna go
i'll go with like version la head or
something
maybe a couple other buddies and i was
already picturing us getting there a
couple days early because we'll do stand
up probably at the star dome or
something
this is the game plan and
in the mornings i just pictured us like
hanging out like [ __ ] eating
breakfast somewhere with the car radio
on
just sitting there in the parking lot
laughing our [ __ ] asses off
getting there's no you if you're not
even into college football if you just
watch
if you can somehow find that um that
roll tied war eagle or war eagle roll
tie depending on who you talk to what
should come first
it's just it puts the yankee red sox
[ __ ] to shame
it really does i i actually think ohio
state michigan puts yankee red sox [ __ ]
to shame i mean the yankee red sox thing
died down now that the sucks finally won
it
um but uh
it's just it's just a whole other
[ __ ] level you gotta check it out
highly recommend it so anyways one last
uh advertising here for the week
um e-voice uh your screening claw okay
you're screening calls closing deals and
making money all while lounging poolside
in the summer sun
thanks to what e-voice everybody e-voice
is a better way to connect with people
that drive your business
e-voice will forward business calls to
your home mobile or any number you
choose
wherever you are e-voice will find you
don't have time to take a call it's
routed to voicemail and you can read it
as your at your own convenience as a
text message
e-voice not only gives you an edge over
your competitors it takes away the edge
the
big competitors have over you right now
with e-voice
you can create the appearance of a whole
office building of departments when
customers call you
a sales department customer support tech
support you name it
it's going to sound like you got a giant
skyscraper with your name on the side of
it
and it works with any phone even
yourself hey it's summer don't be stuck
in your office all day you jackass
free yourself with a three 30-day trial
of e-voice so you can see what i'm
talking about
go to e-voice dot com and enter promo
code bill for your 30-day free trial
that's evoice dot com
promo code bill or go to the podcast
page on billboard.com
and click on the evoice banner there you
go everybody
that would be the advertisement for this
week right i'm done
nice okay let's go on to the next one
uh dating an ugly girl sorry about the
click in here everybody
jesus christ hour and 18. [ __ ] chatty
kathy here
all right doll dollar shave oh
i started reading the advertising i am
so [ __ ] stupid
clicking away dating an ugly girl there
we go see they both started with a d
so that that was enough to get me going
dating an ugly girl hey bill i just
recently listened
started listening to your podcast at
work and i got to say great job man
thank you very much you say some truly
funny and inspiring stuff oh
thank you um i wanted to ask you for
your advice
on a troubling matter of mind i recently
started dating a girl that i met
on an internet dating site that's unreal
i wish that [ __ ] was around when i was
[ __ ] single
and i was a young man had a full head of
hair right
jesus christ that's like going to the
supermarket just picking out fruit
you know ah jesus christ
if you if you're letting your ego get in
the way of [ __ ] doing that you're out
of your goddamn mind
still going out playing a [ __ ] cover
charge
i guess that's the sport of that you
know
not having the gun cocked walking around
with the shotgun
broken over your arm right
having your boy go fl flush him out
flush him out of the [ __ ]
bushes every once in a while though
wouldn't it be nice to fish in a stock
pond
um anyways he said we met on an internet
dating site
we get along great uh we got along great
through emails but when we met i was
surprised to see how ugly her face was
and how slightly off
she smelled
you know i just did such a great
commercial for why you should do
internet dating and
now you've convinced me that i i don't
even know what i'm talking about
all right so what what do you need
advice at this point she has an ugly
face and smells bad
so what ah jesus
that i i just saw it's dating an ugly
girl okay well i'm intrigued no
well what do you look like sir are you a
little off and do you smell
um do your smells combine and actually
smell like something good
can that happen can two negatives make a
positive in smells i know they're doing
math
needless to say i was coming out of a
dry spell
also she has a great body so i put the
moves on her
i never actually hesitated you should
have taken a [ __ ] shower with her
that was the move right there you should
have taken a [ __ ] shower with her and
banged the doggy style
jesus christ do i gotta hold your hand
over to the [ __ ] water fountain
anyways he goes uh so i put the moves on
her i never actually hesitated i just
went on being myself around her
and talking to her and now we're
together the sex is amazing i
[ __ ] knew it i knew the sex would be
amazing because there's no other reason
to stay with somebody's ugly and they
smell
they better [ __ ] the [ __ ] out of you or
uh you know they better find a new
career
because their their [ __ ] game is over um
playoffs now your season's over
you're playing for a first round draft
pick
all right the sex is amazing she has a
pretty deep voice jesus
christ
this is like the money pit except
instead of a house it's a woman
all right she has a pretty deep voice
for a lady so when we
bang it's the only time she talks and
acts like a woman
dude if you get to the end of this and
this person has had a sex change
operation
i'm not going to be surprised um
jesus christ do i continue
yeah i got nothing better i do [ __ ]
and he goes uh blah blah we get along
great
she's like the best friend i never had
yeah i'm sure she probably [ __ ]
lift more weights than you too seriously
we make each other laugh a lot and we're
always learning and growing
intellectually with each other my
dilemma is this i'm a pretty handsome
guy and we go out
when we go out together people always
stare give us angry or confused looks
oh come on man that might be in your
head
i think that a lot of that might be you
being
self-conscious confused look
like why is this great looking guy with
this piece of dog meat
i don't know if that's your ego or
you're dating the ugliest [ __ ] thing
ever
you said she's got a nice body so you
know what i mean
throws on a little makeup does some [ __ ]
with her hair
you know maybe combs it in her face a
little
becomes 50 less uh now this is just
getting meaner by the second uh my
dilemma is this okay blah blah i haven't
introduced her to any of my friends and
family yet because i'm
afraid of what they'll think of me and
how they will judge us behind our backs
also i don't want ugly kids and that's
pretty important
why are you with this person sir
you're saying horrible things she has an
ugly face she smells bad you think she's
going to make ugly children what the
what the [ __ ]
you know what it is your dick is still
making the decisions in your life sir
that's why you're still with this person
and secondly just because you're good
looking
and you get with the good looking person
that doesn't mean you're gonna have a
good looking kid
all right that's one of the fallacies
out there
i can i can name a couple celebrity
couples
drop dead gorgeous had it and had an
average looking kid because you know
what it is
it's not like you're you're beautiful
and you're beautiful so together you
make beauty
no it's you're combining
your features you know what i mean
there's a lot of average you know i can
tell you right now more times than not
average looking people
have stunning kids they have gen or they
have just
as as good a chance of making stunning
kids
this is like that [ __ ] i was talking to
you about like a few weeks ago
when i was talking about like when
people give like michael jordan's kid
[ __ ] because he's not as good as his dad
at basketball it's like well he's only
half his dad
he's michael jordan cut with michael
jordan's wife
okay and if she has no leaping ability
okay and can't even catch a beach ball
underhanded that's gonna [ __ ] with the
sun's ability
to go to the rack you know
so anyway that sir i i'll read the rest
of this book
anyways uh i don't want ugly kid and
that's pretty important me she
she truly is an amazing person and in a
perfect world i wouldn't hesitate to
make her my wife
but the fact is i'm too much of a [ __ ]
to completely accept her into my life
well you know what you're man enough to
admit that you're
you're a [ __ ] that's a good step
uh which it is but i don't really want
to hurt her feelings her life is already
pretty hard because of how she looks
dude what does she live under a bridge
what is the problem
what should i do am i too selfish in
vain
any advice in this matter would be
appreciated well the problem is sir
you've stayed with her long enough that
she's starting to get into your heart
you know she was in your balls first but
then you know
now she's up in in your chest so
[Music]
uh
what would you do i mean well i mean you
have to make the choice look you either
accept her for who she is and you
introduce her to
people around you or you get rid of her
because you're going to hurt her
you know
that's it i don't know what [ __ ] else to
tell you
i hope i didn't come off like a dick
there but i mean that's uh
that's just that's the deal you got to
make the choice all right
okay well that's the podcast for this
week everybody i apologize for being a
[ __ ] and forgetting the the plug and
all that [ __ ]
but um i did take a lot of video
this week that i'm gonna try to have
uploaded onto the podcast page and all
that i'll try to make it up that way
my iphone pictures and videos as i'm
driving
and i know it's not safe to be doing
that you don't need to point out all the
people on the motorcycles i know
that i was taking people's lives in
danger you know endangering their lives
so before you think you're the most
clever [ __ ] on the [ __ ] internet
um all right and send me all your hacky
[ __ ] [ __ ] about first world problems
and all that
those other catchphrases um anyways here
we go wrap ups
all right guys now that the show's over
don't forget to support our sponsors if
you can
get started with the free 30-day trial
of e-voice
as i mentioned e-voice gives you a
toll-free 1-800 number or local number
so you can call
so you can take business calls from
anywhere and always sound like you're at
the office
also evoice has great features like dial
by name directory and even transcribe
your voicemail so you can read them at a
conference all right
go to evoice.com and enter the promo
code build for your 30-day free trial uh
or go to the podcast page billboard.com
click on e-voice
um also don't forget to sign up for uh
hulu plus it lets your bins on
binge on thousands of hit shows anytime
anywhere on your tv
pc smartphone or tablet support this
podcast and get an extended free trial
of hulu plus
when you go to the podcast page
billboard.com and click on the hulu plus
banner
um and finally dollarshaveclub.com
forward slash bur dollarshaveclub.com
forward slash bart
all right you want to stop getting effed
over buying razor blades
not only are you going to get them for a
fraction of the cost they can deliver
them right to your damn house
high quality razors sent to your door
every month for a fraction of what you
pay at retail
i love these guys you will too all right
now go to dollarshaveclub.com just go to
the podcast page on billboard.com and
click on the dollar shave club banner
and that is the show for this week um
thank you so much to everybody who came
out
in boise in bozeman montana for
everybody else deadwood wichita tulsa
colorado springs el paso all of
those other dates i am making those up
i'm doing them two
three at a time two down like eight
cities to go
i'm bringing the t-shirts and i'll do a
nice long show for you
uh because i [ __ ] you over i didn't
[ __ ] you over i got an acting gig what
am i supposed to do
you know but uh i'm gonna make it up to
you all right
thanks for listening and uh go [ __ ]
yourselves
and now there's the long silence because
i can't find the stop button and there
it is